the presumptive nominee Joe Biden as you
know is planning on attacking mr. Trump
on the sweet spot the economy that's
really risky for with the vice president
for a lot of reasons the economy's down
now this second quarter is going to be
horrible but all the economists are
saying that by the summertime in the
third quarter the economy should rebound
so the timing might work out just
perfectly for the president if this if
this v-shaped recovery is in fact what
happens you know in the meantime Joe
Biden also criticizing the president for
for playing golf Jesse it just seems to
me that all these guys since Dwight
Eisenhower have loved to play golf and
then they attack their opponents when
the opponent plays golf maybe they
should all go to Dana's and say bowling
alley and take up a different sport
memory lane sure I least Trump a good at
golf he's probably one of the best
presidential golfers of all time maybe
she should invite Joe out for a round
you know maybe they could play a round
and whoever wins could be President I'd
put my money on Donald Trump I don't
know if Joe can play golf I know he was
pictured in a photograph with hunter and
the guy involved with the bereavement
deal after he said he didn't know the
guy that's about as much I as I know
with Joe and golf but that's all the old
tired attack that's a playbook that
people have used for decades I don't
know if it's going to stick with the
president but I also don't think Joe's
some economic genius I don't think this
guy is going to be able to run on the
economy against President Trump he's
already down double digits on handling
the economy this is going to be about an
economic comeback and you're gonna see a
rocket ship third quarter going right
into November which is going to be tough
to talk around you're gonna see a record
amount of jobs created and a record
amount of GDP growth in that quarter
heading into the election and I don't
think Joe's savvy enough economically
he's never had a real job in his life
he's a lifelong politician it wasn't
even on
economic committees as a senator he was
responsible for the stimulus that went
down the tubes
he just can't hack it on that subject
you know on a different subject Dana the
vice presidential choice don't you think
that the former vice president the Joe
Biden's in a very tough spot because if
he does not pick an african-american
running mate III think that you know
given the Charlemagne that God and all
that stuff that happened he risks taking
away the motivation the energy from a
key constituency so he has to pick a
black vice-presidential candidate but he
also has promised to pick a woman so
he's looking for two historic firsts a
black woman you know how that plays out
I don't know how a professional
politician would assess whether he's in
a good spot or a bad spot Dana well you
ask me if he's in a tough spot and I
think yeah in some ways you could look
at it that way but in another way you
could say it actually makes things a lot
easier because he narrowed it down so
much just by saying that those were
going to be the two boxes that he wants
to check so then he has a smaller pool
from which to choose but I think it's
been pretty interesting about this vice
presidential choices is that you have
these women who are actively campaigning
in the press to be his vice president
I've never seen anything like it like I
I always thought that it was like you
know maybe hey tell Biden I really like
him and I'd love to be his vice
president you just like get a little
whisper in there you get somebody else
to say it for you
not these ladies and I kind of admire it
they're like I would be a great vice
president and you should choose me and
I'm kind of interested to see how that's
gonna turn out John first of all great
say John Rich wonderful to see you
you were my guide during all of
Celebrity Apprentice you were my secret
weapon during celebrate apprentice and I
appreciate you and your great talent you
know that thing about the absentee
ballots the president was talking about
the the at-home balloting the only
recent case of harvesting absentee
ballots at least was the Republican
Harris in North Carolina i I don't know
that voting from home is really that
different than what half of Florida has
been doing right along John well I don't
think it should happen on either side of
it I mean you know I was just listening
about you know about that the ladies
that are actively campaigning to try to
get Joe Biden pick me pick me it's
almost like a political version of the
bachelor and like you know Joe Biden's
got the roads so who is he gonna give
the rose to you know it's it's pretty
crazy I would also say well what about
the fact of how about you pick the best
person that could do the best job no
matter who they are what they look like
you know let's go after the best person
for the job isn't that now we're
supposed to to do it in this country so
to me the whole process of watching him
roll this out to me doesn't make sense
well it it is it is what it is politics
but Emily what do you think about
Gretchen Whitmer's husband would you
would you divorce him if he were her for
appointing to put his boat in the water
when everyone else is being told not to
I mean who knows what is going to happen
in that household behind closed doors
but I honestly felt a little bad for her
no one likes a hypocrite obviously but I
think I think she had a I don't think
she asked for that situation by any
means